24 stories ablaze in 15 minutes
a day later this the fire raged up
beside the tower because experts say of
the cladding that surrounded it 18
months earlier an industry report lay
out precisely the danger
it said we do not believe that it should
take a serious fire in which many people
are killed before all reasonable steps
are taken towards minimizing the risks
Sky News can reveal the residents of the
area presented this specific report to
the council and tenants organization
they say the warning about cladding was
ignored they've known now for over two
years that's even death documented on
the internet you know they knew about
wiring and faulty things even my friends
have complained and you know it's like
they tell you they're gonna sort it but
nothing ever happens we sourced cladding
made from the same materials as on the
Grenfell Tower aluminium layers sandwich
in polyethylene insulation in the middle
we took that material to a safety
testing lab as the aluminium buckles
under the heat the insulation is exposed
it becomes fuel for the fire well if you
look at the material now it's done is
buckled under here's warped you can see
along there it's a lot like the debris
our is picking up yesterday in West
London this isn't just about the
material itself it's about the structure
how this is put together tower blocks
are constructed to be compartmentalized
if a fire breaks out in a kitchen say
fire doors should keep that fire within
the flat elements like the lift shaft
are also fireproof and isolated to stop
fire spreading so is the fire escape the
emphasis is on giving people enough time
to escape while a fire burns cladding
though can bypass those features through
its highly flammable insulation which
will then travel between floors and it
can also contain cavities either by
design or by the fire damaging the
exterior if a flame gets in here it will
shoot up as it seeks oxygen extending up
to five or 10 times its length that
means it can skip up floors if a window
is open on a floor above as many would
have been on a hot London night the
flame can spread back into the building
on another floor what it shows and what
it says is basically that there are
regulations in place in this country
that need to be followed in order to
avoid the risks and if they're not
followed if
that the safeguards associated with
cladding are not properly put in place
then yes there is a risk that cladding
can contribute to a fire 18 months ago
the report said that small-scale tests
for cladding were not an effective way
of evaluating a live fire situation the
husk of Grenfell tower stands as
testament to that
Tom Cheshire Sky News